abigail walker is one thing and she's a
fantastic character and i'm i'm so
grateful and so lucky to get to play her
but she's not the only fantastic
character in this story you know that's
something that that drew me to the
script in the first place is that every
single character you you look at them on
the surface and you meet them for the
first time and you think you know who
they are and you think you know what
you're gonna get out of them and then
suddenly
they present something entirely
different that you know it takes all of
these tropes that we know and love of
westerns and reinvents them and
re-examines them and goes well this is
what we know but is that how the west
actually was and maybe there's more to
the story
is it complicated is it challenging on
set to do i mean what are they asking
you to do what things can you tell me
that you've done
you're obviously riding horses
yes i'm riding horses there's horses
there's shotguns there's
a 20-pound dress
there's a corset there's you know and
and you know the heavy emotional trauma
of having your you know as we see from
the trailer having your husband murdered
in the first you know x amount of
minutes of the pilot that's what happens
yeah that's well you see that you know
as as we start as you get to see the
trailer you uh
abigail walker has set off with her
husband into what she's assuming is
going to be a fresh start and a new life
out west um she's from boston and she
and her husband have decided to take
this journey he's you know meant to be
the sheriff and she is gonna help him
start this new life
um
but her you know her entire within the
first x number of minutes of the show
her entire life her entire world is torn
apart
and she is forced to
start anew and and for a woman in the
1870s to be on her own
and have nothing and no one and be a
complete stranger in not only a new town
but a new world of the west
it's it's daunting but it takes a
character like abiel walker who has the
education and the strength and the
tenacity and the willingness to go
you know what no i'm not gonna let this
defeat me i'm gonna embrace this and she
takes on this agency that you don't see
a lot in women of that time
and she's also surrounded by
a cast of characters men and women alike
who recognize that agency and who give
her the opportunity to
exhibit that and to exert that in this
new world and it's such an exciting
story to tell because it is so
uncommon for a western there is no
shrinking violet there is no damsel in
distress there is no
cowboy who cannot be beaten
there is no
character that is truly good there is no
character that is truly bad there is all
shades of grey and that's the most
exciting thing is that no one comes out
of the west unscathed is there some dark
[ __ ]
there's some really dark stuff really we
we don't shy away from it i mean and
that's what you get when you get you
know a writer like
sheamus and you get a director like
larry and you get this world where i
mean we saw it with the pilot of walker
you know you saw what jared's character
went through and the pilot of that show
within the first 15 minutes it's
they don't shy away from putting these
characters through when you saw what
happened to matt barr's character at the
end of his season of walker there's a
reason that he's now on our show and not
still on that one you know his
characters go through things people die
things change the world is shattered
you